wow  oh my God God I wish I didn't see that  oh I wish I didn't see that it looks  like a magic guy  I put it on my Tick Tock oh my God am I  get that big is that real this kid's got  an insane case of ice oh my God it  haunts me to this day oh I wish I didn't  see it but lice doesn't turn into like  worms like that that's like big ones  dude that kid's head that kid those  things were like setting I don't even  want to keep watching it it's oh God  that is that is that's like maggot-sized  light that's insane I've never seen that  I don't think lice turn into that though  is what I'm saying I feel like that's  something else  it might be I don't know what else it  would be